what's more likely chris
the bears quarterback situation with
dalton and fields plays out like the
2017 chiefs where patrick mahomes was on
the bench until a meaningless game in
week 17 or the 2020 chargers
well
i
well
dr needle i don't know that dr needle is
involved we don't need that what is that
in case he's trying to put the heads on
andy
will the doctor stick a needle in his
lung and make him not able to play
no but
let's just say fields finds a way onto
the field regardless of whether it's dr
needle or some other yeah basis some
other needles right yeah i'm i'm gonna
go with the 2020 chargers model there
you know and the fact that we're going
to see justin fields you know a little
like we talked about with the 49ers
situation and all that you know maybe
even two at a greater degree one like
andy dalton doesn't have you know super
bowl starting quarterback next to his
name right and then the other thing i
just look at too you know with that so
the bears fans are somewhat underwhelmed
as my point with andy dalton as their
starting quarterback and justin fields
is a huge name was the quarterback of a
power school in ohio state and they
traded big time assets to to get him at
pick number 11. so i just think there's
there's no chance we don't see him we're
gonna see justin fields this year
now you know i i looked into this last
week and we talked about during the show
and i eventually wrote something about a
pft
andy dalton is the week one starter
right he's been told that now they could
renege
they could decide
or they could just bring in dr needle
after the third preseason game as the
case may be but dalton when he signed
was told he's the guy to start the
season doesn't mean he's got to finish
this season i i think that at some point
we saw that stretch of games
week six seven eight nine i believe four
very difficult games if memory serves
and it rarely does i think the packers
are in there the steelers are in there
by the time they get to their bye week
there's a damn good chance the bears are
going to be in a spot where they need
the kick in the ass that comes from
putting justin fields into the mix and
they'll get that two weeks to get him
ready after nine of the games are played
and there's still eight to go i i i
think that that it it's just a matter of
time
before fields takes over i i do
currently believe it'll be dalton week
one i do too but i but i think we'll see
fields at some point most likely again
i'm watching that week 10 by because
they're going to come
into that that buy with four very
difficult games yeah i i mean
i i think your assessments their
assessment there is is pretty good i
mean you know also the last thing that i
would just say that kind of jumped out
to what you said too like that boost
that jump that kick in the butt whatever
whatever it is you're talking about
right yeah i mean we've been
underwhelmed by their offense in the
matinee area in the era that's why it's
a little bit like justin fields can give
an element that could maybe spice and
juice things up a little bit to a degree
because of his skill set and his running
and things like that so that's where i
just yeah andy dalton will start week
one i i i wouldn't that doesn't mean
you're
starting the third series of week one
game either or the second series of the
week two game uh there's there's
definitely some wiggle room in that
statement
i think he gets week one yeah and he
gets week two against the bengals for
sure and then after that well who knows
right and isn't that when dr needle
showed up didn't he show up in week
three i thought i don't know i thought
it was early it was week one
yeah i think it was right before the
opening kickoff wasn't it aren't i
correct there
week two oh it was week two it was week
two
you're right that's what it was yep
kirk cousins has an understudy now
who could have been justin fields
instead it's kellen monde here's cousins
speaking about his plan to assist monde
in his adjustment to life in the nfl
you know there was good communication
through the process and
kellen kellen's been great you know
working hard and picking up our offense
quickly so
it's been a good process and um
you know we're just kind of building
this thing right now to uh
uh keep ramping up as we get closer to
september you know you're an open book
you're uh you're
helpful and and you're there and um make
yourself available and um you know i had
rex grossman when i was a rookie and rex
had played in the super bowl and won a
lot of playoff games and started a lot
of games in the nfl and um was in year
10 so it was great to be able to learn
from him and he was a big part of my
early development as a football player
and i really you know took every word
that he said to heart because i felt
like he had been there he had done that
he knew what it should look like and
i hung on his every word so um you know
i've i've been there and
want to certainly be that same resource
whenever possible
okay what's more likely kirk cousins
performance this year makes it clear
he'll be getting another contract to
stay in minnesota beyond 2022 or it'll
be clear by the end of the season that
kellen mond is the future as of next
year uh i mean i
i almost want to say like neither but
like hear me out okay i'm gonna say that
the second part but i don't necessarily
i'm gonna say that's kellan mon but not
necessarily the way that's written out
there like to me i think kirk cousins is
going to have a good year hey he's smart
he knows how to play the game they got
two good receivers they got one of the
best running attacks in football i don't
think there's going to be anything there
looking like that but i do think
minnesota's not going to let them hold
their feet over the hold their feet over
the fire for like this huge monster
contract and he could be one of those
guys where they go like you talked about
we go he's good but he's not special
he's not gonna carry us we're not gonna
pay him 40 million dollars a year we got
a guy that's much less expensive and
just as talented we're gonna go with
that that's where i think this could all
go and that's where i'll put my money on
that question uh your your turn i i i
agree with you look this is a playoff
year for the vikings based upon the high
level analytics of they make it to the
playoffs every other year 15 17 19 21
they're due this year cousins has a good
year but next year when they encounter
difficulty adversity cousin starts the
year as the starter monde has quietly
been developing they get an opportunity
to put monde in the game and monde takes
over from there and then he's the guy
for 2023
week one and beyond i think that's the
way it's more likely to go because look
they're not going to extend cousins he
said he doesn't want an extension he
wants to play out these two years and
then he's going to hit the open market
and i don't think the vikings want to
compete on the open market to keep kirk
cousins and who knows who's going to
want him at that point yeah right knows
who's gonna pay him big money the 49ers
have their future
set and the rams likely do too those
would be the two primary candidates all
right last one real quickly dak prescott
says that he buried thoughts of his
ankle injury a month ago on the dance
floor so what's more likely dak press
got in the cowboys offense pick up where
they left off before the injury or
dallas has a role reversal and the
defense has to carry them early in the
year well there i can't see that
happening i think the defense will be
better with dan quinn but no it's still
about the offense that's where the money
the resources the talent everything
about the cowboys says offense you have
to be the star of the show and kind of
carry the team i would expect that it's
a pretty good system he's a damn good
quarterback it's receivers galore it's a
good all line it's the running backs are
good like it's got to be about that
cowboys offense and i expect it to pick
up where it left off
yeah you know i do too and by all
indications dak is going to be fine he's
still got several more months
their offense is what's going to make
that team go or not go and the defense
it doesn't have to be much better than
last year for them to be a contender
we'll see if it's any better than it was
in 2020.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports